[Music]
uh
and the only eyewitness of the murder
did not show up to make a statement
yet another time you should have seen
the look in his eyes
thanks i told you we would prevail
i think hate them inferior race
hell yeah but they're not inferior just
hateful
[Music]
what do you mean not inferior i mean
they're not
inferior if anything
what are you talking about i'm talking
about basketball running football
boxing everything remember that
huge gorilla from my last fight
but that's only because slavery built up
there exciting ability
you don't know why we just can't call
them
inferior anymore
they've grown a real threat you know
what i mean
a real opponent
so
can you believe i just met this guy who
killed sam
yeah not too far away from here actually
really had to hold back not to spit in
his ugly [ __ ] face
what's in there oh work
i'll check it later
anyway did you try the suit for tomorrow
what
the suit did you try it oh yeah yeah you
know how important this day tomorrow is
don't you and you also know how
important it would have been to your
parents
especially your mother remember how you
saw you'd lead your sister to the altar
come what may you don't have to tell me
what i swear to me
i've grown a real threat you saw you'd
lead your sister to the altar
come what made
[Music]
uh
thanks man no problem
to all kinds of [ __ ]
you still keep a picture of her
it's okay i mean i don't know what it is
it's okay
hey i can't take your call right now
just leave a message
hey hon where are you i'm starting to
get a little worried
coming back as soon as you get this okay
time
gotten down
some famous last words
[Laughter]
what
24 hours please i need 24 hours
i'm not begging for mercy please just
give me one more day
one more day to do what called the cops
on us
my sister she's getting married
and it's important
that's where i won't throw anything out
i'll eat my girlfriend
i'll leave my girlfriend to you
your girlfriend huh
she's black
okay agree oh
come on seriously dennis
but if you're only one second left
a reaper and when i'm done
and you're still not here
then i'll kill her instead of you
where have you been
why don't you call me back
i [ __ ] up really badly i may
i may join the wedding
if
if few stays
as your pledge
sorry
and keep her in sickness and in health
forsaking
all others keep only onto her so long as
you
both shall live i will
inasmuch as you have pledged to the
other your lifelong commitment
love and devotion i now pronounce you
husband and wife your man
[Music]
hmm
everything okay in there
yeah i'm all right
so that's how we meet
i tell you what
who are you let's say
i am part of the power that would always
wish the evil
but always works the good
still think he's coming back huh
jeez you really [ __ ] a [ __ ] like that
you know what i would do i would just
kill her no matter what
unload a whole magazine in her [ __ ]
face huh just think of your wife and
start
shooting up pump pump
cheated on you and you're still clinging
to her huh
but your ex
i'm not yeah i saw that what do you mean
you saw that
i don't know the picture
now there's this whole situation earlier
like
you know what shut the [ __ ] up you hear
me
shut the [ __ ] up nobody's gonna tell me
what i'm gonna do
you got me
and nobody is gonna tell me
who i'm [ __ ] with
you hear me i'm on your side
then [ __ ] stop talking about her
[ __ ] when tomorrow all right okay
yeah i'll be there yeah
everybody's got a weak spot so does he
in fact his is a pretty delicate one
so
we have a deal
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good luck
surprise surprise the dark knight came
back indeed
stay there
get on your knees you don't have to do
this get
on your [ __ ] knees
[Music]
you really [ __ ] a [ __ ] like that
still claim to her huh
think of your wife and start shooting
how
myself
[Music]
where's the other guy hon i don't know i
think he left
[Music]
go to the cup
i'll be right there
[Music]
[Music]
and what to do
[Music]
laughs
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you